タイトルについてです。
週刊金融日記 第七百五十号、アメリカのアジアピボットが頓挫して米中衝突リスクは軽減され、日本にとっても良い方向であるという内容になっています。
それから、SoftBankが史上最大規模のジャンク債でOpenAIへ追加投資した件、福岡の天神パルコのレストランフロアにあるラーメン屋が行列で入れなくて、噂の干物定食チェーン店に行った話、中部電力の不甲斐なさなどについてもお話しします。
それでは、こんにちは。
ふじさわかずきです。
きのうまで熊本地震の復興支援を兼ねて、寸断されていた九州新幹線が再開したその初日に合わせて鹿児島旅行に行ってきました。
いろいろ勉強になることがあったので、また改めてメルマガでも触れたいと思います。
ちなみに、そのあと福岡空港から香港に戻ってきました。
香港と九州、けっこう近いんですよね。
錦江湾では釣りもしてきました。
桜島はやっぱり圧巻でした。
霧島くらいマイナーなスポットだと、外国人観光客はほとんど見かけません。
でもシルバーウィークの影響で、国内の人でかなり混雑していました。
おそらく、外国人観光客が多く訪れる日本の観光スポットって、実は限られている気がしました。
尾崎牛の刺身がめちゃくちゃ美味しかったです。
Xサブスク（月に三米ドル）についてですが、アップルやグーグルにピンハネされてしまうスマホのXアプリからではなくて、宇宙開発を応援するためにも、天才イーロン・マスクさんのXのWebをブラウザで開いて、そこで直接ポチっていただけるとうれしいです。
こんしゅうは株価もだいぶ下がってきて、米中の融和も進みそうだなというところで、そろそろだと思って中国企業のエーアイレポートをアップしました。
それからMicronは言うまでもなく、超重要な企業なので、こんやからあしたくらいには決算前レポートも上げる予定です。
美団 二千二十六年第二四半期は予想を超える黒字で、内巻現象は終わったのか（Xサブスク）。
CATLは過去最高益にも関わらず株価が下落、世界一の電池会社は今が買い時なのか（Xサブスク）。
こんしゅうも読者のみなさんから興味深い投稿がいくつも届いています。
主な見どころをいくつかご紹介します。
・鹿児島の鳥刺しでおすすめのお店について紹介します
・中部電力の惨状を見て、やっぱり原発再稼働は難しいのでは
・半導体製造装置で最大手のエーエムエーティーについての投資はどう考えますか
・職場で同僚の女性が育児を理由に早く帰ることで、そのしわ寄せが自分にきています
・中高一貫進学校出身者は、じぇーてぃーしーの管理職に向いてない気がします
・恋愛工学を嗜み、ずっと独身でやってきましたが、大きな病気をしてから老後への不安が急に大きくなりました
それでは、こんしゅうもどうぞよろしくお願いします。
続いて、「アメリカのアジアピボットが頓挫して米中衝突リスクは軽減され、日本にとっても良い方向である」についてです。
せんしゅう、中国のしゅうきんぺい国家主席が約十一年ぶりにワシントンを国賓訪問しました。
その歓迎ぶりは、中身としては特に大きな進展や決定がなかったと言われていますが、映像的にはまさに異例のものでした。
トランプ大統領とメラニア夫人がわざわざメリーランド州のアンドルーズ空軍基地まで出迎えに行ったのですが、現職のアメリカ大統領が外国の首脳をこの基地でみずから迎えるのは、一九六二年以来の異例の事態なんです（ちなみにローマ教皇の出迎えを除いての話です）。
上空ではB-1やB-2爆撃機、F-22戦闘機が祝賀飛行をしていましたし、ホワイトハウスの公式晩餐
[EN]会には、Tim Cook、Jensen Huang、Elon Musk、Sam Altmanら米テック界の錚々たる[/EN]
顔ぶれが勢ぞろいしていました。
見た目としては、かつての激しい対立が嘘みたいに、米中が打ち解け合っている雰囲気で、いわゆる「ジーツー体制」の再来を思わせる演出でした。
晩餐会では、一九七二年にニクソン大統領が中国を電撃訪問したときにやった「平和の乾杯」と同じ、カリフォルニアのシュラムスバーグというワイナリーのスパークリングワインが振る舞われていました。
でも、これを見て真っ青になったのが日本政府や日本の保守派なんです。
訪米直前の国連総会で、高市早苗首相は「国連憲章における旧敵国条項の早急な削除」を熱弁し、日本の保守層はかなり盛り上がっていました。
しかしその直後、ホワイトハウスの壇上でトランプ大統領としゅうきんぺい主席が満面の笑みで強調したのは、「米中は第二次世界大戦で肩を並べて戦った同盟国だった」という歴史的な共闘でした。
フライングタイガース、つまり真珠湾攻撃直後からビルマや中国南西部で日本の陸軍航空隊と戦ったアメリカの義勇航空隊の武勇伝とか、アメリカ海兵隊の合言葉「ガンホー」、これは日中戦争中の中国で抗日物資を自給するために結成された手工業協同組合運動から来ている言葉なんですが、こういった話を持ち出して米中の絆をアピールし、中国側も抗日戦勝の流れでこれに同調したんです。
つまり、日本は外交的に見事なまでにハシゴを外された格好となったわけです。
このへんの日中戦争や第二次世界大戦、それからその後の台湾問題などについては、常識としてしっかり勉強しておきましょう。
ここからは、「パワーバランス一位と二位の宿命：リアリズム超入門」としてお話しします。
国際政治の力学を感情論や「民主主義対専制主義」みたいな、くだらない道徳劇で理解しようとしても無理です。
国際関係を冷徹に分析する地政学的リアリズム、特にジョン・ミアシャイマー教授が提唱している「攻撃的リアリズム」の論理は、ものすごくシンプルです。
中央政府がいないアナーキー、つまり無政府状態の国際社会においては、国家の究極の目的は「自分の生存」なんです。
そして、誰も助けてくれない冷酷な世界で大国が自分の生存確率を高めるための唯一確実な方法は、ライバルに圧倒的に勝る「より強大なパワー」を手に入れることなんですね。
だから、世界の覇権国でナンバー１を自認しているアメリカは、自分の地位を脅かすナンバー２の中国が台頭してきたら、それを叩き潰しにかかるのが鉄則となります。
実際、一九八〇年代から九〇年代初頭にかけて、日本企業が世界のハイテク産業を席巻し、日本のジーディーピーがアメリカの七割に迫っていたときには、アメリカは日本をなりふり構わず叩いた歴史があります。
『週刊金融日記 第七百三十四号 読めば誰でも五分で分かる！
かつて世界を制した日本のメモリ半導体興亡史』もぜひ参考にしてください。
このリアリズムの視点から見ると、オバマ政権がピボット・トゥー・アジア戦略を打ち出してから、ワシントンの戦略家たちは声を揃えて「欧州や中東の局地的な紛争から手を引いて、全資源を唯一アメリカを凌駕しうる相手である中国との対峙、つまりインド太平洋に集中すべきだ」と主張し続けてきました。
その間、日本が対中国で軍事衝突した場合には、先兵として使われるという意識もあって、かなり露骨な反中国プロパガンダも展開されてきたわけです。
『週刊金融日記 第六百三十九号 中国脅威論について』も参考にしてください。
続いて「実際にはアジアからピボットせざるを得なくなったアメリカ」についてです。
現実はどうなったのかというと、アメリカのアジアピボットは、戦略どころか物理的にも頓挫してしまいました。
泥沼と化したウクライナ戦争でロシアを消耗させるために、膨大な弾薬を吸い取られたうえに、二千二十五年からのイスラエルとイランの直接衝突、さらに二千二十六年にはアメリカとイスラエルがイランと戦争をするに至って、米軍の兵站が本当に尽きてしまったんです。
米軍が保有していた巡航ミサイル「トマホーク」は、総在庫およそ三千百発のうち千発がわずか数週間で使い果たされました。
戦略防空の要であるサードミサイルの迎撃弾も、在庫の四〇から八〇パーセントを消費した試算が出ています。
パトリオットミサイルもおよそ二千三百三十発から七百五十九から八百二十七発へと、三分の二近く失われた格好になっています。
アメリカの防衛産業基盤は弱体化していて、これらの再補充には早くても三年から五年以上かかるとみられています。
さらに致命的なのは、ミサイルの誘導装置やモーターに必要な重希土類の精製が、ほとんど百パーセント、アンチモンの精錬も大半を、中国が握っているという事実です。
中国はこれらの輸出規制も着々と進めていて、アメリカとしては兵器を増産したくてもその原料の蛇口は北京が完全に握っています。
二千二十三年にアメリカのシンクタンクCSISが試算したところによると、もし台湾海峡で事態が発生した場合、米軍の長距離精密誘導弾は「開戦から一週間足らず」で底をつくとされています。
その後イラン戦争で在庫はさらに減ったので、今はもっと早く尽きる可能性が高いです。
[EN]●Empty Bins in a Wartime Environment: The Challenge to the U.S. Defense Industrial Base[/EN]
[EN]●Last Rounds? Status of Key Munitions at the Iran War Ceasefire[/EN]
[EN]●The First Battle of the Next War: Wargaming a Chinese Invasion of Taiwan[/EN]
「中国に対抗するために欧州・中東からアジアにピボットする」と言っていたはずが、実際には「欧州と中東に戦力を吸い尽くされて、物理的にアジアからピボットせざるを得なくなった」というのが、いま目の前で起きている地政学の生々しい現実です。
『週刊金融日記 第七百号 中国が独占状態のレアアースと希少金属：アメリカ経済を破滅させることができるカード』
『週刊金融日記 第七百二十二号 ペルシャ湾岸諸国のおかげで台湾有事で日本でいったい何が起こるのかが確度高く具体的に分かりました』
続いて「日本の保守派の勘違いと代理戦争の駒にされる危険性」についてです。
日本の保守論壇では、「アメリカが中国に対して強硬姿勢を取れば取るほど、日本の安全保障にとってプラスだ」と無邪気に信じている人が少なくありません。
彼ら
まずは、アメリカを対中戦争に引きずり込んで、米国の圧倒的な軍事力で中国を屈服させてもらおう、なんて夢想してしまっている人たちがいますが、自分たちが「アジアのイスラエル」になれると勘違いしているんです。
でも、これは完全に妄想で、日本にとっては破滅的な発想なんです。
イスラエルがアメリカの軍事力を本当に動かせるのは、議会の超党派の強い支持や、AIPACに代表される強力なロビー団体、そして数千万人規模の福音派キリスト教徒という厚い支持基盤が、何世代にもわたってアメリカ政治の中枢にしっかり根付いているからなんですね。
アメリカはいろんな国を代理戦争の駒に使うことはあっても、世界で唯一、アメリカに代理戦争をやらせることができる国、それがイスラエルなんです。
それに比べて日本が米国の国家意思を自由に操るパワーなんてあるんでしょうか。
そんなはずはありませんよね。
日本がアメリカを代理戦争のコマのように使いこなすことなんて、百パーセント無理なんです。
現実の日本が置かれている立場は、「アジアのイスラエル」なんかではなくて、どう見ても潜在的には「アジアのウクライナ」なんです。
米中両国は、地球を何回も滅ぼせるくらい強大な核戦力を持っています。
だから、米中の正規軍同士が直接本土を撃ち合うような第三次世界大戦なんて起きるわけがないんです。
ここで『週刊金融日記 第六百四十四号 NATO対ロシアの核戦争がテールリスク程度には現実味を帯びてきたので核戦略理論の復習』のことにも少し触れておきます。
核保有国同士が本気で対立した場合、軍事的に採られるのはただ一つ、「核を持たない周辺国を鉄砲玉にした代理戦争」です。
では、もしアメリカが本気のアジアピボットを継続して、対中強硬路線を突き進んだ場合はどうなるでしょうか。
核戦争を避けたいアメリカは、安全な自国にいながら遠隔で武器だけ供与し、日本や台湾に前線で血を流させるというシナリオを強く志向するはずです。
米中が直接対決するなんてことは起きないまま、日本がアメリカの駒として中国のミサイルの飽和攻撃を浴びて、国土が焦土になる可能性が高いわけです。
これが「米国の対中強硬」の先にある結末なんです。
訪日したアメリカの国防長官も、有事になれば「日本は最前線になる」と、対中抑止の姿勢をはっきり示していました。
続いて、米中融和が日本国民にとってどういう意味を持つか、お話しします。
トランプ大統領は本音ではずっと孤立主義、もんろーしゅぎを志向していて、ここに米軍の兵站の問題が重なってアジアピボットは物理的にも頓挫せざるを得なくなったんです。
こうして現実のパワーバランスや、将来的な衝突の可能性を考えれば、米中が「戦術的デタント」、つまり融和へ舵を切ったことは、日本国民の生存にとって「非常に良いシナリオ」だと、僕は考えています。
首脳会談で、トランプ大統領がしゅうきんぺい主席と第二次世界大戦の同盟関係を称え合って、日本の頭越しにディールを進める様子は、対米従属一辺倒でやってきた外交関係者にとっては、屈辱的で、まるでハシゴを外されたように感じるかもしれません。
でも、大国同士が直接手を打つ方向になったことで、日本が「アジアのウクライナ」として破滅的な代理戦争に巻き込まれるリスクは一気に遠のいたわけです。
力強い発信や勇ましい意見に惑わされず、米中の間で、衰退気味の中堅国として、大国の顔色をうかがいながらしたたかに立ち回ることでしか、平和は守れません。
ここからは、こんしゅうのマーケットについてです。
2026年9月18日から9月25日までの週間のパフォーマンスを振り返ります。
[EN]TOPIX:       4128.59, +0.9% (1w), +20.5% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Nikkei225:  66364.20, +2.1% (1w), +31.8% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]S&P500:      7743.41, +1.2% (1w), +13.1% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]USD/JPY:      157.18, +0.7% (1w),  +0.5% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]EUR/JPY:      179.12, +0.0% (1w),  -2.5% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Oil(WTI Fut):  92.41, -7.9% (1w), +60.9% (YTD)[/EN]
米中の融和が世界経済にとってプラスとなったことや、ソフトバンクが史上最大となるジャンク債でオープンエーアイに追加投資したこと、さらにMicronの決算に注目が集まっています。
これは金融日記 Weekly 2026年9月18日から25日のまとめです。
せんしゅう、つまり9月18日から25日のかぶしきしじょうは、シルバーウィークで日本しじょうの取引日が少ない中、エーアイ関連株が再び相場を引っ張りました。
TOPIXは週間で0.9パーセント、日経平均は2.1パーセント、S&P500は1.2パーセント上昇しました。
アメリカではメタが13.0パーセント、エーエムディーが12.6パーセント、マイクロンが6.5パーセント、マイクロソフトが4.5パーセント、TSMCが3.7パーセントなど、それぞれが上昇し、日本でも東京エレクトロンが6.4パーセント、アドバンテストが6.1パーセント買われています。
一方で、中東ではアメリカとイランが段階的な停戦とホルムズ海峡の再開を模索しているという報道があり、WTI原油の先物は1週間で7.9パーセント下落して92ドル台まで戻しました。
戦争が終わったわけじゃありませんが、100ドルを超えていた原油のリスクプレミアムはひとまず剥がれました。
最大の政治イベントは、言うまでもなくしゅうきんぺい国家主席の異例とも言える国賓訪米でした。
トランプ大統領自らが空港で出迎えたんですね。
首脳会談では、関税休戦が2カ月延長されたものの、レアアースや先端技術規制、台湾などの核心部分は先送りされました。
とはいえ、パワー第一位のアメリカが第二位の中国を叩きたいという地政学的な構図が完全になくなったわけではありませんが、少なくとも中短期的には、両国が正面衝突を避けて、いろいろ取引しながら関係を安定させる方向へ動いているように見えます。
トランプ大統領もしゅうきんぺい主席も、関係の安定を強調していて、今回の首脳会談は大きな問題を解決したというよりも、米中対立が管理できる範囲に収まる「戦術的デタント」の色合いが強いです。
僕個人としては、この米中融和の流れは歓迎すべきことだと感じています。
世界第一位と第二位の大国が軍事衝突や終わりのない経済戦争へ進んでしまえば、悲劇的な結末を迎えるのは明らかだからです。
トランプ大統領としゅうきんぺい主席は、米中は第二次世界大戦の同盟国だったと言っています。
良くも悪くも、米中関係は融和に向かっているんですね。
そして今週はソフトバンクグループがオープンエーアイへの追加出資などをまかなうため、ドル・ユーロ建てで総額百十一億ドル、およそ一兆七千億円のハイイールド債を発行しました。
これは、世界のハイイールド社債として過去最大となり、最長七年半のドル建て債券は利率が九・七五パーセントという水準になっています。
オープンエーアイへの累計投資額が六百四十六億ドルに達する見込みで、エーアイ投資のきぼはどんどん巨大化しています。
先週のソフトバンクグループの株が二・六パーセント下がった理由は、これだけ高い金利で資金を調達して、本当に元が取れるのかという点に、しじょうが懐疑的だからかもしれません。
そして今週、エーアイ半導体相場の最大のイベントとして注目されるのは、三十日のMicron決算です。
株価は先週六・五パーセント上昇していて、決算への期待も高まっています。
会社の第四四半期ガイダンスは売上高五百億ドル、粗利益率が約八十六パーセント、調整後一株利益三十一ドルという、非常に驚きのある数字です。
前回決算では、長期的な供給コミットメントを積み上げて、メモリの供給制約が二千二十七年を超えて続く可能性まで示していました。
僕はMicronの業績について何も疑っていませんし、エーアイデータセンター投資とメモリ不足が続いている限り、再び驚異的な数字が出てくることには確信を持っています。
しじょうが注目しているのは、二千二十七年のHBMやディーラムの需給や価格、設備投資、そしてこの異常に高い利益率がどこまで続くか、ということなんです。
すでにかなり高くなっているしじょうの期待をさらにどこまで上回れるのか。
そして、好決算が出た時に株価がどう反応するかが、非常に気になるところですね。
「旧敵国条項」削除に「強い思い」で触れた首相の話や、しゅうきんぺい氏がアメリカに到着した際に、空港までトランプ氏が出迎えたこと、その厚遇の裏にある焦りや打算の話。
また、トランプ氏が「中国は同盟国だ」と述べ、しゅうきんぺい氏は「日本軍国主義と戦った」という歴史観を語ったこと、トランプ氏も「中国は大戦時の同盟国」だと応じ、しゅうきんぺい主席の抗日歴史観に危うく呼応したことについても、最近の話題です。
ソフトバンクグループがジャンク債で一兆八千億円、ドル建ての利回りが九・七五パーセントで過去最高だということや、エーアイじゅようの拡大でマイクロン株が年初来二百六十パーセント以上上昇し、九月三十日の決算でその持続力が問われていること。
加えて、美団の二千二十六年第二四半期が予想を超える黒字で「内巻」が終わったのかというXサブスクでの話題や、CATLが過去最高益でも株価が下がった件、世界一の電池会社が今買い時なのかという話も出ています。
Xサブスク、つまり月三ドルで、主要企業の決算分析や、エーアイバブルがいまどこにあるのか、筆者とエーアイによる対談記事も読むことができます。
もし購読希望の方がいれば、アップルにピンハネされるiPhoneアプリからではなく、スマートフォンやパソコンのブラウザからXのサイトを直接開いて、そこでサブスクリプション登録をしてください。
ついでに、イーロン・マスクさんの宇宙開発も同時に応援できたらいいですね。
ここからは今週の経済カレンダーについて簡単にお伝えします。
まずは九月二十八日、月曜日には、日銀金融政策決定会合の議事要旨、七月三十日と三十一日に開催された分が公表されます。
次に九月二十九日、火曜日には、日本の四十年国債入札。
アメリカでは七月のケース・シラー住宅価格指数、八月の雇用動態調査、いわゆるJOLTSの求人件数。
そして九月の消費者信頼感指数が発表されます。
九月三十日、水曜日には、日本の八月の鉱工業生産指数、八月の商業動態統計、そして二年国債の入札も予定されています。
アメリカでは九月のADP雇用統計、四月から六月期のジーディーピー、確定値が出て、八月の個人所得・個人消費支出、PCE、九月のシカゴ購買部協会景気指数が発表されます。
中国では九月の製造業購買担当者景気指数、中国九月のRatingDog製造業購買担当者景気指数もチェックポイントになっています。
ここからは、ブログには書けないお店についてのお話です。
福岡の天神パルコのレストランフロアにあるラーメン屋さんが、行列でなかなか入れなかったので、噂になっている干物定食チェーン店に行ったお話です。
こんしゅうは、霧島の話を書こうと思っていたんですが、帰り道にちょっと寄った福岡がとても面白かったので、その話を忘れないうちに書いておくことにします。
ちなみに、少し前までは香港と鹿児島の間に直行便があったのですが、今はもうなくなってしまって、福岡経由になったんです。
この日は、鹿児島から夕方に福岡にやってきて、天神のビジネスホテルのようなところに泊まり、次の日のお昼過ぎの便で香港に帰る予定でした。
メルマガを書いていたら夜もかなり遅くなってしまいました。
グーグルマップで調べてみると、屋台のような場所や、夜中まで営業しているラーメン屋さんがたくさんあって、「さすが博多だな」と思いました。
ただ、グーグルマップで評価が四・二点以上のラーメン屋は、天神にいくらでもあるんですが、夜の十時過ぎにもかかわらず、前を通るとどのお店もみんな行列に並んでいるんです。
仕方がないので、ぶらぶら歩いて、並ばずにすぐ入れるラーメン屋さんに入りました。
ここで適当に入ったごく普通のラーメン屋さんのレベルが高すぎて、思わず笑ってしまったんです。
僕は、品川駅みたいな飲食が充実していない場所でラーメン屋を探してみたり、香港だと体にやさしい中華のスープ麺が美味しいので、わざわざ塩分や脂や旨味が強い日本のラーメンはあんまり食べないんですけど、博多の普通のラーメン屋さんのレベルは本当に高かったです。
入ったお店は「二代目けんのすけ 天神本店」で、住所は福岡県福岡市中央区天神一丁目十三ー十三、電話番号は〇九二ー七一三ー七一一三です。
その日は、寝るだけのビジネスホテルで一泊して、次の日は飛行機に乗る前に日本のデパートで買い物する予定でした。
朝起きて、開店直後の天神の大丸などに行き、順調に買い物を楽しみました。
それにしても、昨夜食べた博多ラーメンがあまりにも美味しかったので、ランチもまたラーメンにしようかな、なんて考えていました。
デパートのおばちゃんとおしゃべりしていると、たくさん買い物してくれるのは中国の人たち（ここには台湾や香港の人も含まれているんでしょうか）、そして韓国の人ばかりで、欧米の人は全然買い物しないそうなんです。
いろいろ調べていたら、天神パルコの地下の飲食店フロアに、グーグルマップで評価が四・二以上のラーメン屋さんが何軒かあるんですね。
そういえば去年紹介した担々麺のお店も、このパルコの地下にありました。
博多は、とりあえずパルコの地下が間違いなさそうです。
『週刊金融日記 第六百七十九号 博多で美味い担々麺を食べながら学歴の遺伝について考えた』でも書いていました。
開店してすぐのデパートで買い物して、パルコの地下に来たのが午前十一時くらいだったので、人気の博多ラーメンもすぐに食べられるだろうと思ったんです。
でも、それが甘かったです。
いくつかお店があるんですが、全部午前十一時からもう行列でした。
「みんな地元の人なのか、観光客なのか分からないけど、そんな朝からラーメン屋さんに並ばなくてもいいのに」と思いました。
自分はわざわざ香港から来て、もうすぐ帰らないといけないから、席を譲ってほしいくらいです。
流石に、前回紹介した「担々麺」のお店は十一時くらいなら並ばなくても入れたんですけど、メルマガの取材もあったので、同じお店に行くのもなぁと思い、適当に焼き魚の定食屋に入りました。
ランチの生ビールが税込み二百三十一円で、思わず笑ってしまいました。
ここはチェーン店なんですけど、ウェブサイトを見ると値段が書いていなくて、多分、お店ごとに値段が違うみたいで、東京のお店ではここまで安くないと思います。
たぶんですけどね。
サンマの塩焼き定食が美味しかったです。
二百三十一円のビールをおかわりして、イワシの塩焼きも追加注文しました。
あとで気がついたんですが、ここは噂になっている焼き魚のファストフードで、インフレが進む東京のサラリーマンや学生の救世主にもなりつつある「しんぱち食堂」でした。
そういえば、すかいらーくに買収されて、どんどんお店が増えているんですよね。
安くて美味しいカジュアルな和食はとても珍しいので、大戸屋と並ぶライバルになりそうですし、海外でもきっと成功できそうな予感がします。
すかいらーく、「しんぱち食堂」の定食業態を百十億円で買収して都市部を開拓したというニュースもありました。
炭火焼干物定食「しんぱち食堂」天神パルコ店の住所は、福岡県福岡市中央区天神二丁目十一ー一、福岡パルコ本館地下一階で、電話は〇九二ー七〇七ー一一〇六です。
今回、シルバーウィーク中だったから、夜でも昼の十一時でも、博多のラーメン屋があんなに並んでいたのか、普段からも並んでいるのかは分かりません。
短い滞在でバタバタしていたんですが、博多自体は大変賑わっていました。
後世に残す金融日記レストランリストNo.1
後世に残す金融日記レストランリストNo.2
後世に残す金融日記レストランリストNo.3
後世に残す金融日記レストランリストNo.4
後世に残す金融日記レストランリストNo.5
金融日記レストランリストNo.6 飲食が充実していない品川駅周辺の美味しいお店
しんせん・南油服装卸売しじょうの歩き方 2026年
続いて、ふじさわかずきさんの身もフタもない人生相談です。
今回は、鹿児島の鳥刺しでおすすめのお店を紹介しますという話題ですね。
こんにちは。
鹿児島の鳥刺しの話題が出ていたので、メールさせてもらいました。
私は鹿児島に定期的に数年間通っているのですが、鳥刺しなら谷山にあるこのお店が美味しいと思いました。
鹿児島県鹿児島市上福元町三七〇九ー三
電話番号は〇九九二六九二五五八です。
テイクアウト専門店で予約必須とのことです。
ここからは、ふじさわかずきさんの回答です。
食べログのページもなく、地元の人しか知らないようなお店ですが、インスタグラムにはちょくちょく写真がアップされていますね。
これは見るからに美味しそうですね。
谷山といえば、日本最南端の路面電車の駅がある場所で、近くにはあのラ・サール中学校・高等学校がありますね。
鹿児島市電谷山線の沿線となります。
『週刊金融日記 第五百四号 こどもを寮のある学校に入れれば中学受験は割に合います』
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十九号 鹿児島で美味しい鶏刺しを食べながら生食規制について考えました』
鹿児島というのは、本当に何を食べても美味しいですよね。
ここからは、中部電力の体たらくを見ると、やはり原子力発電所の再稼働は困難なのではないか、という話題です。
こんにちは。
いつも参考になる論考をありがとうございます。
今回は原発について、というより電力会社についての質問です。
藤沢先生が以前からおっしゃっている、経済的には原発の再稼働が最適という考え方には僕も賛成です。
しかし、中部電力の最近の状況や、他の電力会社でも似たようなことがあったのを見ていると、この先十年、二十年たっても再稼働は無理なんじゃないか、という気がしています。
浜岡原発データ不正で中部電力の社長と会長が辞任へというニュースもありました。
再稼働に向けて、組織体質やガバナンス面での壁を乗り越える術はあるのでしょうか？
私は、こういった組織の問題が解決できず、再稼働はかなり困難じゃないかと考えています。
ふじさわかずきさんの回答です。
ダメだと思いますね。
日本は民主主義の国なので、政治家たちは（ほぼ常に間違った政策判断をしてしまう）有権者に迎合してばかりですし、公益事業で独占している電力会社は、特に原発という面倒なものを動かさなくても、電気代にコストを転嫁すればいいだけですし、場合によっては電気代を払うしょうひ者も愚かですからね。
中部地方には、キオクシア、トヨタ自動車、デンソーなどが集まっていて、日本の製造業の屋台骨にもなっているのに、浜岡原子力発電所が再稼働しないせいで、電気代が高いままなんですよ。
大手電力会社十社の地域別電気料金比較ランキングというのもあります。
僕はこういうことがあるので、民主主義をあんまり信用していません。
『反原発の不都合な真実』という話題もあります。
続いて、半導体製造装置最大手AMATへの投資についてはどう考えますか、という相談です。
いつも有意義な世論解析をありがとうございます。
質問させていただきます。
【質問】
手持ちのドル資金に余裕があるため、全世界株式、いわゆるオルカンを中核とするポートフォリオにおいて、半導体製造装置最大手のApplied Materials、略してAMATをサテライト投資として組み込もうかと考えています。
アプライド・マテリアルズですね。
なぜかというと、AMATはエーアイという「現代のゴールドラッシュ」において、金を掘るプレイヤーではなく、最先端の半導体製造装置という「ツルハシ」を独占的に供給する元売り企業であると考えたためです。
ただ、一方で、どのタイミングで購入するかはとても悩んでいます。
藤沢先生だったら、どのような指標を参考にして購入のタイミングを決めますか？
また、そもそもこの企業への投資が悪手だと思う場合、他にどんな企業に注目しますか？
ふじさわかずきさんの回答です。
アプライド・マテリアルズは、いくつかの指標で見ると世界最大の半導体装置メーカーで、もちろん非常に重要かつ有望な企業ですよ。
言うまでもなく、うちのエーアイアナリストもきちんとカバーしています。
半導体製造装置の世界最大手Applied Materialsは重要なので、決算前と決算後、それぞれレポートを出しています。
最後に、職場で、同僚の女性が育児を理由に早く帰り、その分のしわ寄せが自分に来ています、という相談が届いています。
ここからは、職場での働き方やキャリア観についてのご相談です。
私は、およそ五人ほどのチームで働いていて、残業代はなく、年俸制なんです。
同い年の女性の同僚がいまして、その方はいわゆる育児を理由にして、在宅勤務が多め、参加するミーティングは少なめ、仕事もあまり受けない、アウトプットも少なめで、ほぼ朝九時から夕方五時までの業務をしています。
いっぽう、私は九時から二十時まで働いています。
年俸制なので、その同僚の年収ははっきりとはわかりませんが、おそらくそんなに大きな差はないと思われます。
時給に換算したら、私のほうが低い気がするんですよね。
タイトルはわずかに私の方が上なんですけど、上司も育児バリアに対しては強く言えず、注意もしないという状況です。
もちろん年俸制なので、ここはジェーティーシーではないんですが、頑張れば年収は上がります。
ただ、そんなに劇的には増えません。
いわゆるベースアップにちょっと毛が生えたぐらいです。
藤沢先生なら、こうした状況でどうされますか？
将来の昇格や昇給を目指して今のまま業務に打ち込めますか？
それとも、働く時間やアウトプットを同僚に合わせてもう少し抑えたほうがいいのでしょうか。
それとは別に、私は創刊号からこのメルマガを読んでいます。
私自身、大学生から妻やこどもを持つようになるまで時が流れ、恋愛工学もいつのまにか使わなくなって久しいです。
藤沢先生も、同じように変化があったのかもしれませんが、たまには恋愛工学の記事もぜひお願いします。
ここからは、ふじさわかずきの回答です。
成果とか、上司に気に入られるかどうかで報酬が大きく変わるわけでもなく、また、クビになることもめったにないのが日本の企業、あるいは日本社会の良いところなんですよね。
育児でほとんど時短勤務になっている同僚と給料がそこまで大きく変わらなくても、そこは文句を言っても仕方ないかなと思います。
それが嫌なら、歩合制の営業みたいな仕事に就くとか、すぐにクビになるけど、うまくいけば報酬が高い外資系企業に行くという選択肢もありますよね。
人と比べるから不満が溜まるのであって、別に比べなくてもいいんじゃないでしょうか。
はい、恋愛工学の記事もがんばります。
ここからは、恋愛工学の重要なバックナンバーとして中高一貫進学校出身者についての話題です。
中高一貫進学校から私立の文系、そしてジェーティーシーの管理職になりました。
正直なところ、中高一貫進学校出身者って、ゼネラリストであるジェーティーシーの管理職にはあまり向いていない人が多い気がします。
正確に言うと、管理職向きの教育を中高一貫校できちんとやっていない、というほうが正しいかもしれません。
私自身、いま使っている能力は中高一貫校で学んだことよりも、私立の文系でワイワイやって得た能力が大半だと思っています。
そしてそれは、私が大学受験に失敗して私立の文系に進学したからこそ得られた能力のようで、なんとなくエリートがモテないという恋愛工学にも通じる部分があるんじゃないかと感じていますが、いかがでしょうか？
これに対して、ふじさわかずきの回答です。
ペーパーテスト一発勝負という文化は、良くも悪くも、ある意味で徹底した実力主義なので、基本的にはジェーティーシーの管理職みたいなものには向いていないと思うんですよね。
こうした受験勉強って、どちらかというと内向的な人が得意なんじゃないでしょうか。
『週刊金融日記 第三百五号 外向型人間vs内向型人間』
まあ、オープンエーアイやアンソロピックのようなところでエーアイの研究や開発をやるとか、ヘッジファンドで自動売買のモデルを作るとか、そこまで行けばいいんですが、東大に受かったぐらいでは、そんなに勉強ができるということでもないですし、大半の人は、出世したいなら管理職的な役割に進んでいくしかないんですよね。
さらに、生成エーアイのすごい進化のおかげで、財務分析だったり、言われたことをコーディングするみたいな、受験エリートに向いているような仕事もどんどんエーアイに置き換わっていく傾向があると感じます。
とはいえ、僕自身は、日本のペーパーテスト用の教育を支持する立場ですけどね。
『コスパで考える学歴攻略法』
続いて、恋愛工学を実践して独身生活を送ってきた方からのご相談です。
いつもメルマガを楽しみにしています。
恋愛工学を学んで、二十代、三十代は独身生活を謳歌してきました。
四十代も半ばに差しかかったことし、大きな病気をして手術と一週間の入院生活を経験しました。
入院中にはお見舞いに来てくれる家族やパートナーもおらず、これまでの人生を振り返ることになりました。
また手術の時の緊急連絡先には、七十代の親の名前を書かざるを得ず、親が亡くなったら緊急連絡先に書く相手もいません。
ここ数年で性欲も食欲も大きく減退し、老後への不安が急に強くなってきたんです。
藤沢さんは、こういった不安を感じたことはありませんか？
ふじさわかずきの回答です。
たしかに、年を取ると、基本的に男性の性欲は減っていくものかもしれませんね。
あと、僕はコンピ地獄の本なども書きましたが、昔から一貫して、結婚そのものを否定しているわけではなく、むしろ結婚を推奨する立場でした。
特に、日本の女性たちは、結婚というカードをとても高く買ってくれるので、年収が数千万円もいかない場合は、ほとんどの男性にとって結婚というカードを切るのは、長い人生で見ると合理的だと、何度も言ってきました。
『週刊金融日記 第二百五十七号 続・人はなぜ結婚するのか　結婚カードを巡るプレイヤー別最適戦略の研究』
『損する結婚 儲かる離婚』
僕の場合は、性欲が減ったいっぽうで、知識欲や学問への興味がまた楽しくなってきたりして、それを最先端のエーアイがものすごく助けてくれるようになってきたんですよね。
ちゃんと教科書が揃っているような分野なら、あらゆる分野で、説明がうまいトップクラスの大学教授のレクチャーが使い放題になったようなものです。
あと、良くも悪くも、おかねへの欲も減ってきたかもしれません。
おかねが増えても、もう生活が変わらないですからね。
そうなると、一周回ってアカデミックなことが楽しいので、一部の優秀な学生が、給料が安くて雇用も不安定なアカデミアを志すのも、そこまで変な話じゃないのかもしれません。
僕の場合は、アカデミアに情熱があったから途中まで目指していたわけじゃなくて、実際にはアカデミアがいちばんコストパフォーマンスが良くて、留学や自分のスキルアップに役立ったから進んだというだけなんですが、ここ最近は純粋にいろいろなことが面白くなってきました。
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十八号 エーアイにより我々の知的生産性は爆上げしてめちゃくちゃ多忙になり暮らしに余裕もなくなりましたが収入も増えません』
究極的には、人間の原動力って、まずは生物としての遺伝子の乗り物であるということと、もうひとつは文化的なミームをどう残していくか、この二つに集約されていくようにも思いますね。
ここまでが恋愛工学の重要なバックナンバーのご紹介でした。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。